bruh did you see that knockout this week
oh yeah you posted it he's not oh you're
saying this that knockout did i put
who posted it knock out no they're not
with the kick right
oh yeah you're saying the greatest
knockout yeah exactly
i don't think i will it's it again it's
tough to say greatest fall time but it's
top
five that was top five top five you guys
see it yeah
that was crazy i think it's one of the
most watched
uh highlights of ufc ever though that
came
that kid he kicked his face off they
don't have it on there no no i haven't i
don't have it yeah it was on there it
was on sportszone that was insane
that looked like me and malik fighting
out there too bruh it was nuts
just the way we haven't seen the way he
you know we've never seen somebody do it
that way
and he's a heavyweight right oh no oh
yeah what's his weight
no i think they're are they 155 170
oh heavyweight you ever seen a
heavyweight doug well yeah
oh no i'm saying they love you well
you're a heavyweight of course yeah
those guys no those guys aren't
heavyweights but uh damn you struggling
to fight nothing
damn chance chin is only the greatest
knockout
struggle bus over here super strong
i mean it literally happened
i'm gonna get a good one i'm gonna get
it right if you go to twitter just ufc
i know right ufc twitter hold on
i got this i got this he's going through
the wrong page he's making the lebron
you see this yeah chin's bad at dinner
he's going to animal planet to look it
up
let me get through this stuff just a
bunch of ducks and like
hey look i was like i didn't know y'all
was gonna go to be this early i didn't
know
should i ever get my stuff together now
k.o right
it's hard to say uh grace of all time
just because it was on the prelims
the stakes aren't as high like to me
it'd be hard to put that
over amps and silva front kick in for
the [ __ ] out yeah because that was for
the world
title yeah and that was the main event
it's like vitor belfort is like one of
the greatest ever do it yeah i'm not
saying those guys are bad fighters but
neither one's one of the greatest to
ever do it not yet anyway
yeah they're young okay but as far as
athletically [ __ ] dude i mean
nuts there it is
[Music]
for one he should have been knocked out
for that haircut two uh
that's what you don't think about that
dude flew all the way to abu dhabi
got knocked out the worst knockout we've
seen in years yeah and he's going viral
for that then he has to wake up to that
the next day he's like oh [ __ ]
and then get on a plane and fly 18 hours
back to where the [ __ ] he's from
i know that's what nobody talks about
and he's getting half his pay when i got
knocked down i lived right down the
street
you know what i'm saying what do you
mean you got knocked out by who uh it
was in
uh this kid in junior high and i told
you before oh yeah
is the king of the singers on here i
think king oh i told him
yeah he got knocked out mm-hmm by like a
younger kid right yeah he was younger
and shorter
he was little you didn't tell me this
yeah i did
they removed it from sportscenter shout
out to robert would you say they took it
off sportscenter
it said restricted because too violent i
don't know maybe oh [ __ ] the way his
works are a bunch of [ __ ] they can do
that wait he's right here right there
oh that was so quick 12.5 million it has
to be the most viral clip of all time
for ufc yeah i retweeted it
[Music]
yeah damn that was devastating but i
would never want that to happen to me i
cracked i'd rather get that that's like
worst case scenario like yeah that's
worse there's nothing
like when you're visualizing back in the
locker room you don't visualize that
but you're really like oh man if he
beats me i know right yeah
i don't want to get tired what if you
get a clip
behind the air yeah if someone's like
hey dude
you're gonna hold on his foot he's doing
a spinning heel kick and knock you the
[ __ ] out
and then he's gonna go viral and 40
million people are gonna watch it and he
did that that was quick
you gotta get some jordan that was so
quick the middleweights yeah yeah you
gotta get some jordan
joaquin buckley give him some jordans or
some vans they know his name now
hell yeah he's a striker everyone's
gonna be looking for him now oh really
st
louis well they'll be looking forward to
his next fight you don't go that viral
or not
yeah nuts now now you got to live up to
that i know he was talking [ __ ] after
right i heard him no he wasn't yeah
he was in the gate well he's just
excited he's just talking about [ __ ] no
no no he's
a bad sport he's pretty right but when i
get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like you look like a rottweiler
you gotta [ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son